[Música]
14 líderes mundiales en activo y 21 que
ya dejaron el cargo escondieron fortunas
de miles de millones de dólares para no
pagar impuestos así lo revela el
consorcio internacional de periodistas
de investigación en los llamados papeles
de pandora entre los señalados están el
presidente de ecuador- guillermo lasso y
de chile sebastián piñera que negó su
implicación analizamos en esta emisión
en mexico activistas antiaborto marchan
en diferentes regiones del país en
contra de la decisión de la suprema
corte de despenalizar la interrupción
del embarazo los ciudadanos piden que el
aborto vuelva a ser un delito y aseguran
que el asesinato no es una cuestión de
derechos
entre dos mil novecientos y tres mil
doscientos sacerdotes y otros miembros
de la iglesia católica francesa fueron
culpables de abusos sexuales contra
niños desde la década de 1950
esta es la revelación del más reciente
reporte de una comisión independiente
que además indica que se trata de una
estimación mínima
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torre sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos una nueva
investigación del consorcio
internacional de periodistas de
investigación revela que 14 líderes
mundiales que se encuentran en sus
cargos escondieron fortunas de miles de
millones de dólares para no pagar
impuestos asimismo otros 21 que ya
dejaron el poder también encubrieron
propiedades e ingresos los documentos
hacen parte de los llamados papeles de
pandora que involucran a más de 300
funcionarios públicos de 90 países del
mundo para analizar esta información
conectamos con carlos eduardo huertas de
la alianza editorial 'el espectador'
conectas quienes lideraron la
investigación de los papeles de pandora
en colombia gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 hay millones de
archivos que se han analizado que ha
analizado el consorcio internacional de
periodistas de investigación como los
obtuvieron
bueno valentina muchas gracias por la
invitación y del consorcio de
periodistas de investigación es una
organización global que tiene tres
fortalezas primero ha logrado construir
redes de colegas efectivas de
periodistas a nivel de global que
trabajan en investigaciones de largo
aliento de investigaciones complejas
como estos segundo han tenido la
capacidad de desarrollar mecanismos para
manejar grandes volúmenes de información
en este caso el de pandora felipe se
administraron cerca de 12 millones de
documentos relacionados con 117 países y
participaron 600 periodistas y
adicionalmente tienen la fortaleza de
lograr mecanismos y canales para manejar
esta información con con seguridad si en
este caso aunque tener una jurisdicción
offshore no o en un paraíso fiscal
técnicamente no es un delito el alto
nivel de secretismo y las atractivas
ventajas tributarias de estos
territorios han permitido que algunos
clientes puedan evadir impuestos en sus
en sus países puedan lavar dinero o
puedan esconder lo de ahí que sea de
gran alerta que muchos mandatarios en
especial en américa latina' aparezcan en
estos registros
justamente usted lo estaba mencionando
vemos que en la nueva revelación hay 14
jefes de estado o líderes de países
quienes son los más reconocidos en la
región en américa latina y como se
explica que estas personalidades se
verán envueltas en estos delitos porque
uno podría pensar que por el contrario
son los que deberían dar el ejemplo
si totalmente de acuerdo bueno lo
primero es que no creo que en este
momento ninguna de las publicaciones ni
de conecta si el espectador que
trabajamos la información en colombia ni
de nosotros aliados del consorcio en
américa latina hayan señalado
puntualmente un delito porque esto es
precisamente lo que tienen que hacer las
autoridades tributarias pero tomando el
caso de colombia desde las primeras
revelaciones en el año 2016 hasta el año
2021 o sea durante cinco años ha habido
varias revelaciones del mismo estilo
lideradas por el consorcio de
periodistas de investigación eso a
colombia le ha significado un mayor
recaudo de impuestos cuánto ha recaudado
impuestos el país un trillón de dólares
4 billones de pesos 4 millones 300 mil
pesos un trillón de dólares y uno le
podría decir a cualquier ciudadano de a
pie porque debería interesarme esto
bueno hay hay un trillón de razones por
las cuales deberían interesarnos esto o
sea las leyes y las
exigencias tributarias que tienen
nuestros países
y encontrar en estos destinos acceso
solamente para poderosos que encuentran
esguinces y fisuras dentro de las normas
y dentro de los esquemas tributarios
para esconder sus fortunas en estos
casos de los presidentes no tenemos esa
confirmación pues cada uno tendrá que
revisar frente a la autoridad tributaria
según sea el caso si estos son
bienes e ingresos no declarados pero en
esta oportunidad digamos el alcance que
tiene la investigación al lograr acceder
a la información en más de 14 fuentes
diferentes es evidencia que si bien se
ha avanzado todavía falta mucho por
avanzar porque si son precisamente los
poderosos los que tienen que tomar
decisiones frente a estas jurisdicciones
y ellos hacen parte del esquema
seguramente el asunto todavía sigue con
unas fisuras importantes
bueno pues este tipo de movimientos para
esconder fortunas no es algo nuevo y son
muchos los personajes importantes que
serán beneficiados entonces a quienes
les corresponde reforzar los controles
para que esto no siga ocurriendo
bueno los primeros obviamente son las
autoridades tributarias y las
autoridades que en cada país tienen que
ejercer este tipo de control pero la
ciudadanía creo que
como un efecto incluso de la pandemia en
donde los gobiernos han tenido que
aumentar sus impuestos han tenido que
buscar cómo financiar sus programas
sociales pues han apretado mucho más
este tipo de
exigencias a los ciudadanos en común yo
creo que en países ya se han dado
manifestaciones en donde la ciudadanía
dice bueno si vamos a estar todos en la
misma cama estemos con las mismas reglas
y eso yo creo que es la demanda general
que hay detrás de este tipo de
revelaciones carlos eduardo muchas
gracias por este análisis que nos
comparten france24 estamos muy
pendientes de lo que pueda ocurrir en
otras noticias méxico vive una jornada
de movilizaciones de grupos antiaborto
que rechazan la decisión de la suprema
corte de declarar inconstitucional la
penalización de la interrupción del
embarazo con el color azul claro que los
representa y en algunos casos por tanto
símbolos católicos los ciudadanos
marcharon en ciudad de méxico para
exigir que el aborto vuelva a ser
penalizado
no se puede legitimar una ley que no sea
que no que no que no persigue el bien
común porque a fin de cuentas las leyes
están para perseguir el bien común no a
costa sí a costa de un bien individual
que es el del no nacido y el de más
indefenso estoy diciendo aquí sí a la
vida porque todos tienen derecho aunque
no estén fuera del viento desde el
vientre todos tienen derecho a vivir y a
ser respetados un informe de la comisión
independiente que investiga los casos de
abusos sexuales en el seno de la iglesia
católica francesa concluyó que desde
1950 unos 3.000 pedófilos en esta
institución que dejaron miles de
víctimas el documento es fruto de una
investigación de más de dos años y será
presentado el martes al público
previamente conversamos con marcial
sánchez gaete experto en historia de la
iglesia católica quien nos explicó cómo
es posible que los abusos ocurrieron
durante un período tan largo sin ser
frenados
lo que pasa es que hay un problema serio
la iglesia católica que ya se está
denotando no solamente la iglesia
francesa
eeuu austria polonia
entre otros países sin alemania han
parte han comenzado este tipo de
investigaciones debido a que se ha
sabido de estos abusos
sexuales contra niños dentro de las
reparticiones de esta institución esto
es tremendo esto es muy muy doloroso
pero muy doloroso para cada uno de los
estados y también es un problema serio
para la iglesia católica que tiene que
hacer frente a esta situación hoy día
estamos conociendo los casos de en
francia- 3.000 casos según los
antecedentes que tenemos pueden ser más
casos hay un problema de cultura hay un
problema de encubrimiento hay un
problema de un encubrimiento sistémico
hay un problema sistémico de la iglesia
católica que lamentablemente me
atrevería a plantear en los últimos 50
años que estudio este estudio tiene 70
en los últimos 50 años ha sido presa de
muchos jóvenes ha sido presa de muchas
menores de edad y es un problema grave
es un problema grave que no solamente
sustenta a la población francesa sino me
atrevería a plantear a la aprobación a
la población católica en general y ahí
están las responsabilidades la pregunta
quiénes son los responsables los
responsables la iglesia la iglesia
francesa los responsables son los que
cometen el abuso obviamente o los
responsables del vaticano yo creo que
acá estamos frente a una situación de un
encubrimiento sistémico que ese otro
problema que aquí en este informe
probablemente lo van a dar a conocer
aunque se habla ya de 3000 pederastas
que es un número bastante importante y
podría ser más muy doloroso este domingo
argelia prohibió a los aviones militares
franceses circular en su espacio aéreo
en medio de una creciente crisis
diplomática entre francia y su antigua
colonia la medida se produce horas
después de que argelia retirará a su
embajador en parís y que el presidente
emmanuel mccomb acusar a al país de odio
a francia veamos el informe
los aviones de guerra franceses ya no
pueden utilizar el espacio aéreo de
argelia aunque no se ha hecho ningún
anuncio oficial para ir recibió el
mensaje después de que rechazaran a dos
de sus aviones francia usaba la ruta
para enviar aeronaves desde y hacia la
región del sahel donde 5000 de sus
efectivos ayudan a los aliados
regionales a luchar contra los
yihadistas este es el último movimiento
de la creciente tensión diplomática
entre francia y argelia que ha empeorado
tras las declaraciones de macrón citadas
por el diario le monde el sábado según
el artículo el líder francés criticó el
sistema político militar de argelia por
reescribir la historia basándose en su
odio a francia la nación argelina post
1962 ha vivido de la idea de que francia
es el problema desde su independencia la
élite gobernante argelina está compuesta
por militares de la guerra de liberación
de los años 50 por su parte macrón llegó
a cuestionar que la nación existiera
antes de ser colonizada por francia
estuvo que el sistema se había
debilitado debido al movimiento
prodemocrático que derrocó al presidente
abdelaziz buteflika como respuesta a
argelia retiró a su embajador de parís y
acusó a macrón de interferir en asuntos
internos ante esta situación inaceptable
que han dejado estas declaraciones
irresponsables consigo el presidente de
la república decidió llamar
inmediatamente a consultas al embajador
de argelia en la república francesa la
tensión y aire latente entre ambas
naciones a raíz de la decisión de parís
de reducir en los visados a ciudadanos
de argelia marruecos y túnez
vamos a españa tras dos semanas de la
erupción del volcán cumbre vieja en la
isla de la palma el gobierno central
anunció que aprobará un paquete de
medidas económicas que incluye 206
millones de euros para ayudar en la
reconstrucción del lugar desde la isla
el presidente del ejecutivo español
pedro sánchez expresó su solidaridad con
los damnificados las autoridades han
contabilizado unas mil edificaciones
destruidas y cerca de seis mil personas
evacuadas el informe es de andrea maya
la isla de la palma es una de las
mayores preocupaciones del gobierno
español su reconstrucción tras la
erupción del volcán cumbre vieja tomará
tiempo y un presupuesto de más de 200
millones de euros que hace parte del
plan especial para recuperar la región
el próximo martes consejo de ministros
va a aprobar un paquete de medidas muy
potente muy potente desde el punto de
vista de la reconstrucción de
infraestructuras de la respuesta al
problema del suministro del agua también
de empleo también de agricultura también
desde el punto de vista del sector
turístico también desde el punto de
vista de los beneficios fiscales por un
importe total de 200 millones de euros
la mayoría de construcciones afectadas
por la lava han quedado en ruinas cerca
de 30 kilómetros de carreteras están
inutilizables y casi 6000 personas han
sido evacuadas
todas las personas se encuentran en un
alojamiento digna la emergencia
alojativa está superada y también
estamos garantizando este aspecto para
las personas que tienen algún tipo de
dependencia ya son más de 1000 las
construcciones afectadas por la colada y
ese reto les aseguro que también ha sido
complicado desde hace dos semanas la
isla de la palma es víctima del
destructivo fenómeno natural la
actividad explosiva del volcán no está
cerca de calmarse siguen apareciendo
nuevas coladas y centros activos en el
interior del cráter por ahora las
autoridades no saben cuándo acabará la
erupción el paquete financiero anunciado
por sánchez este domingo hace parte de
la segunda etapa el plan de
reconstrucción en la primera etapa se
anunció una ayuda de 10,5 millones de
euros para asistencia inmediata
alemania conmemoró 31 años de la
reunificación producido tras la caída
del muro de berlín en 1989 en medio de
una ceremonia que contó con la presencia
de 16 jefes de estados federales y
líderes religiosos la canciller angela
merkel hizo un llamado a la unidad y la
lucha contra el odio tras su discurso la
mandataria que próximamente dejará el
poder recibió una prolongada ovación
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a ustedes gracias por su sintonía
recuerden que pueden ampliar toda la
información en nuestra web france24
puntocom continúen con nosotros con más
entradas 24
[Música]